the Phantom troop want to have a party
but they're missing a centerpiece so
event planner extraordinaire crawler
Lucifer suggested the perfect thing when
he demanded that the troop bring him
hisoka's dead and severed head pretty
dark but hey to be honest hisoka kind of
deserves it and the Phantom troop are
going to turn this entire ship upside
down searching for that one dead head
hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for an assortment of
psychotic spiders my name is Liam and I
come from Australia which makes me the
most qualified to talk about spiders in
any sense and the basic rule is if you
see a spider in Australia you run which
is a similar philosophy that we can
apply to our manga spiders the Phantom
troop also known as the world's most
notorious and Unstoppable group of
criminals their simple presence aboard
the Blackwell one threatens anything and
everything to do with our dark consonant
voyage and this video is going to be
part 5 of a recap series designed to
give you all of the knowledges you need
to jump straight into hunt Hunter when
it returns later this year and one of
those previous videos was very important
because it lays the foundation for
everything Happening Here deal Dr
killing Soaker in Heaven's Arena crolo
summoned the troop to me to board the
black whale 1 where the plan was going
to be to rob the various Treasures of
the khakin Empire however two troop
members never made it aboard due to
being killed by a now Undead and or
re-life tisoka and the troop did not
like this at all at all each of them
were able to secure passage on tier 5 of
the black whale also known as the place
where all of the poor people are which
means that the Phantom troop really do
fit right in because most of them are
from meteor City so if anything these
conditions I would say is something of
an upgrade for them also this video is
sponsored by nordvpn the world's leading
VPN and easy to use service with over
5500 servers in 59 different countries
allowing you to find a fast server close
by to consume your delicious forbidden
contents as an anime fan one of the
biggest pains in my three-dimensional
butt is geoblocking but we can fix this
a VPN is a virtual private Network that
encrypts your internet traffic as well
as hides your IP and virtual location
from various nefarious entities in
addition to boosting your privacy and
security a VPN also allows you to bypass
geoblocking as it routes traffic through
remote servers allowing you to access
all of the mighty contents it's also
great for gaming I mean if a game isn't
available in your country then whatever
nordvpn allows me to choose from 59
different countries to pretend that I
existed which means that all of the
games will be mine sorry about that but
that's just how it has to be and you can
get exclusive access to a nordvpn deal
through the following link which is a
discount on a two-year plan with a bonus
month for free and it's also a risk-free
30-day money-back guarantee so do that
thing but for now back to you me upon
boarding the ship head Spyder crolo met
up with spider Dr marchy both of them
absolutely enraged about these hisoka
related developments to the point where
Machi tried to call dibs on killing
hisoka but crolo said the classic thing
about the troop is that all members are
theoretically equal and disputes are
always settled with a coin flip however
in this case each and every troop member
wanted to brutally kill murder hisoka
which means that we would have needed
some sort of 10-sided coin to settle
things in the traditional way Banner a
10-sided die like you know with d10 like
this could have happened they did not
try hard enough one thing to note is
that Machi has much more personal stakes
in this matter than most of the troop do
because it's heavily implied throughout
hunter hunter that she and hisoka have
something of a complicated clown romance
happening so in machi's case think of
this as your creepy boyfriend murdering
your almost as creepy brothers so things
are very personal for machi personal and
creepy inevitably the remaining 10
members of The Troop reunited around a
lunch table in the peasant dining hall a
move that would go on to cause a
shocking amount of controversy but for
now the troop introduced a new member
being a certain illumi zoldik and
according to illumi hisoka put out a hit
on himself and had illumi join the troop
in order to put all of his spider eggs
in one black Whaley basket illumi took
on spot number 11 which was uvokin's
previous number but ilami is not the
only zoldek Trooper here as Carlito's
old dick Still Remains a member and you
may or may not remember probably not but
kawato's motivation for joining the
troop was to quote save my brother we
still don't know which brother that is
or how joining The Troop helps matters
in any any way shape or form but I would
say that Carlito is the only one not
necessarily 100 aboard the hisoka murder
train should say that this also isn't
the first time that crawler has worked
with illumi either illumi was hired to
murder the ten Dawns back in York New
City so they do have something of an
established working relationship however
I do want to highlight one big red
raging throbbing flag which is that it's
entirely possible that this this is not
illumi and it is in fact hisoko in a
clever disguise keep a very careful eye
on Mr zodik because he's acting very out
of character to say the least and
hisoka's new post-mortem and abilities
would certainly allow him to mimic the
bodies of others much like how illumi's
needles allowed him to transform into
hisoka during York New City I have a
whole video elsewhere detailing that
theory but I am close to 100 convinced
that this is not illumi anyway we don't
get too far because our meeting is
rudely interrupted by mafioso determined
to claim this particular lunch table and
this is where things start to get
complicated so these dude guys are
members of the Chara family one of the
three Mafia groups that collectively
control tiers 3 4 and 5 of the black
whale and being world famous criminals
each Mafia group actually recognizes the
Phantom troop and certain mafia members
are actually Fanboys like we have inner
monologues of them going oh my God oh my
God oh my God the troop but more
importantly everyone recognizes them as
a threat after a brief conversation with
crolo old man with rose on face that's
that's the only name we have because he
doesn't have one in any case he becomes
stoically terrified that the troop have
no interest in obeying the unspoken rule
of net that unspoken rule being
she can't speak it but the troop aren't
even trying to hide their Aura and that
threatens the very delicate balance of
this Jenga tower that the family
subscribed to play and protect in any
case rather than cause some sort of
scene crawler relinquishes the table but
he says that they will be back well more
specifically we want to have a party but
there's no cake we need a special order
to place at the center of the table
bring me hisoka's head and from there
The Troop disperse into five separate
groups each on the same mission to find
and kill hisoka and the first of those
groups is team crawler now troop leader
doesn't get too far before shizuku and
banal enough request to team up because
allegedly their nun abilities are a very
bad matchup against hisoka's bungee gun
they say allegedly because banolinov is
a dude that can literally summon the
planet Jupiter and Chuck it at people so
who would have thought the heart counter
to such power would be children's candy
but crolo agrees on the condition that
he be the one to actually kill hisoka
which is met with no objection in fact
shizuku and banolanov both plan to act
as Scouts she's a coup through assaulted
dress-ups and Bernal enough through
assorted
he reveals a special addition to the
battle cantably Arsenal called
metamorphism which supposedly allows him
to transform into a wide variety of
quote things however Bernal enough fears
that he does not have the Strategic mind
to properly make use of it meanwhile
crolo definitely does and in fact being
able to transform into different things
and people was a core part of the
strategy that originally killed hisoka
shizuka also requests that crolo read
their fortunes again like he did in
yorkner however rather shockingly
crawler reveals that the lovely
Ghostwriter ability has disappeared from
his skill Hunter book essentially
confirming that somehow neon Strat has
died which could have happened in a
couple of different ways I mean after
losing her ability her family would have
been very easy targets for their Mafia
Rivals but also in a much much darker
twist neon may have actually killed
herself either way shizuku then chooses
this moment to make a black joke the
crawler skill Hunter is kind of like a
Death Note because recently everyone
whose abilities have gone into that book
have died shall not cortopi the meteor
City Elder and now even neon meanwhile
the bulk of this story right now
actually takes place what team thinks a
group of Heavy Hitters consisting of
fata Nobunaga and of course the
aforementioned Finks even though
individually each one of them are
supremely confident in their clown
slaying prowess they wanted to team up
to make sure that hisoka has no chance
whatsoever in order to get things going
though Nobunaga and feitan need their
weapons which were checked into a
storage facility in order to initially
get aboard the ship so they go to the
warehouse in this this is where things
get wild immediately stumbling into a
conflict between the three mafia
families being the Char who run
operations on tier 5 and a
representative of the hail Lee family
who have command of tier three so it's
time to finally do this quick Mafia
breakdown each of the three families is
directly connected to one of the kakin
princes who serve as their benefactor
aka the money these families are led by
illegitimate [ __ ] in royalty for example
the Char R and zeu families are led by
the hilariously named onior and broccoli
or broccoli who are the illegitimate
half-brothers of king nasabi that's why
they've got scars on their faces by the
way the two scar system is used to Mark
someone's legitimate illegitimacy
meanwhile the Hailey family is led by
one of nasubi's illegitimate daughters
Morena prudo and Morana is a problem
like a big big problem earlier I stated
that the objective of The Three Families
was to maintain balance however that was
before Mirena staged a coup and
installed herself as the new Haley
leader or the hail leader for short and
morena's goal is now essentially to
destroy everyone and everything she's
not happy she's not happy at all and she
also has a terrifying net ability called
contagion whereby she can infect up to
22 people who then enter a fun nen game
that nen game involves killing whenever
an infected member kills they level up
and after a certain number of levels
they manifest their own unique nun
ability and if they make it to level 100
AKA killing 100 people then it allows
them to infect a further 22 people just
as Miranda did so this is basically a
way of speed running building and then
Army what he needs to do is kill and you
will be granted more power bringing us
back to the troop now they witness a man
named to luinia member of the Haley
family desperate desperately leveling up
to the point where he has quickly
developed his own teleportation style
netability meaning that by the time we
encounter the weenie he has killed at
least 20 people that's that's a lot but
at this point the troop get caught by
the Char and the boss whose name is
hilariously Wang however both groups do
something I would say shockingly
reasonable which is they talk out the
situation logically instead of jumping
to conclusions and commencing a fight
battle and as a result team Finks
actually end up forming a temporary
alliance with the Chara family offering
to kill both luini and Morena in
exchange for being able to take passage
to the upper decks to search for hisoka
and whilst under boss Wang does agree in
the background he's plotting something
something quite Sinister as his inner
monologue alludes to divorced from
balance unreserved with no allegiances
they move how they want and they have
the power to execute on it as I feared
they are a risk factor that must be
eliminated and not only that but oniar
and broccoli also decide that in order
to preserve the balances they ought to
find and kill hisoka before the troop do
and also Mirena they also want to kill
Moreno in fact the very last thing that
happened in chapter 390 was the GU and
the boss Henry bigendofner being ordered
to launch an attack on the Hayley family
and launch he did because his inability
allowed him to turn guns into snakes and
then have the snake shoot their snake
bullets at the people holding the gun
took cool but brutal meanwhile another
part of the troop that splinted off with
his old dick siblings who somehow made
it all the way up to tier 3. I say
somehow because that's a big part of why
Finks and the others agreed to help the
mafia because there was seemingly no
other way up to the higher tiers but the
zaldics accomplished it only to be
caught in the midst of a tier-wide
lockdown the two were then intercepted
and interrogated by the Zodiac muzai
storm who essentially [ __ ] his cow pants
upon realizing that the entire Phantom
troop was aboard the ship which has also
given me zeistan a bit of a wrong
impression here he thinks that the
trooperable boards take revenge on
karapika which is a fair enough
assumption just like hisoka krapika also
killed two members of The Troop right
now mizai storm is struggling with the
decision of ah whether or not to tell
krapika because from his perspective
krapika's life might be in very very
danger very Danger however his life is
currently already in very danger due to
being caught up in the succession war
and does karapika really need more on
his mind right now but as for the last
we know of Carlito and olami they have
been confined to special Quarters on
tier three and ilami specifically
requested a room with a shower which is
a very unillomy-like thing to ask for
however it would be a very standard
hisoka need now electing to engage in
the complete opposite strategy is one
Franklin Bordeaux who is doing nothing
but sitting and waiting patiently he
knows that hisoka is also on a mission
to kill the troop so Franklin reckons
while I bother searching he'll find me
which I think is fair enough really the
only troop member that we have yet to
check in with is Machi U VI the process
of elimination is assumed to be on her
own very interesting meta point right
now originally Machi was supposed to be
dead Togashi had initially planned on
killing Machi after hisoka vs crolo
however for as of yet unknown reasons
Togashi felt compelled to let Machi live
and aside from crolo himself Machi is
definitely the member with the most
stakes in this conflict and a ton of
room for emotional exploration as
opposed to someone else we really
haven't touched on yet a certain
emotionally devoid rat man who is
suspiciously visually absent but is also
currently making his way to the Dark
Continent along with long-time deadly
rival Jing freaks which we will be
exploring in the next video